le mouvement coopératif a façonner
l'histoire économique du Québec qu'on
pense aux caisses populaires Desjardins
ou en agriculture au groupe solio
autrefois la Coop fédérer mais 100 ans
après sa création la plus grande
coopérative agricole au pays fait face à
dimensions
on a le plus beau catalogue de
machinerie qui peut pas exister c'est à
sa coopérative que Laurent Bousquet de
la présentation près de Saint-Hyacinthe
a acheté ces tracteur
[Musique]
ces instruments-là ont été créés je vous
dirai pour s'assurer que ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque le Canadien français
essentiellement dans le domaine de la
production agricole est un contrôle sur
son activité économique et ne soit pas à
la merci d'entreprise étrangères qui
souvent cherchant à maximiser des gains
votre délaisser par exemple des
producteurs excentriques
[Musique]
vous savez on achète à travers le monde
pour les producteurs d'ici on a des
installations tout le long du
Saint-Laurent pour recevoir les
fertilisants sortir le grain des
producteurs en 100 ans on a bâti des
actifs
au vert dans plus d'une soixantaine de
pays principalement sur l'email ce gros
chevelu
de petits gestes
de dimensions humaines
solio connu jusqu'en 2020 comme la Coop
fédérée devant ta nouvelle de 8
milliards de dollars 16000 employés une
coopérative né au Québec devenue un
géant canadien son président le
producteur avicole et de grandes
cultures Ghislain
gervaises mais c'est toujours sur
Youtube dirigé gouverné par les
agricoles solio c'est devenu trois
grandes divisions la quincaillerie avec
Groupe BMR les viandes avaient colimel
production transformation et
distribution de port et de volaille
et solio agriculture avec la
distribution des semences fertilisant et
commercialisation des grains des fermes
pour le producteur de Gray Laurent
Bousquet il existe une relation de
confiance entre sa coopérative et lui
c'est ce lieu qui va acheter le blé puis
qui va procéder à la solution ou la
vente au détail de la semence produite
avec ce champ là auprès de tous les
utilisateurs de son réseau
c'est arrivé que j'ai pas eu le prix que
je voulais avoir que mon produit mais je
sais qu'on a fait des efforts importants
pour m'obtenir le meilleur prix
[Applaudissements]
les fondateurs de solio sont les
coopératives agricoles de villages
[Musique]
de relations avec la coopérative c'est
quand j'étais enfant mon père recevait
le gérant de la coopérative d'Alta qui
sont aujourd'hui les directeurs généraux
ou les chefs de direction le recevait
autour de la table de la cuisine chez
nous pour discuter de façon hebdomadaire
des fonctionnement de la Coop signer
l'échec nécessaire au fonctionnement de
la croix puis nous autres les enfants
bon tourne autour de la table on
écoutait ça puis on a été imprégné de
cette culture là
[Musique]
donc l'église a été un peu comme c'est
le cas pour des cases populaires
l'Église a pu énormément des jardins
donc l'Église c'est énormément investi
dans le développement des premières
coures agricoles et aussi on peut pas le
faire l'état
il fallait inventer une structure dans
laquelle les agriculteurs exercent un
contrôle
se sortir de la misère le seul un des
moyens que ceux-ci ont trouvé pour leur
faire atteindre les objectifs c'est de
se mettre ensemble la force collective
et les coopératives agricoles se sont
multipliées il y a vraiment eu une
occupation du territoire dans le fond a
des mesures où il y avait des
producteurs agricoles donc Nutella
coopératif il y aurait pu y avoir des
régions sous-développées au plan
agricole absolument absolument parce que
là en ayant cet instrument coopératif on
peut influencer par exemple
c'est-à-dire d'une usine de
transformation d'un entrepôt
la prévisionnement carburant par chance
voulu aller amener de l'essence puis du
diesel à l'autre bout du monde la
fédérer
après son temps le principe du partage
des bénéfices aux membres s'appliquent
toujours
[Musique]
le vrai capital investie dans une
coopérative c'est Natacha Lander plus on
achète dans la coopérative plus on ne
susceptible de bénéficier de restants
parce que l'Aristote de calculer sur la
Chalendard donc ça peut être
considérable ça peut être des fermes
pour qui c'est plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de dollars
devenu la plus grande coopérative
agricole au pays elle est toujours face
au même défi quand on compare avec une
entreprise
[Musique]
d'autres grandes coopératives ont tenté
le coup et ont disparu dont la géante de
l'Ouest Saskatchewan
dans cette coopérative là dans des
années 90 décide de convertir ses parts
en action et attention d'aller sur le
marché boursier à la Bourse de Toronto
dans l'espoir d'aller chercher des
capitaux mais vous savez c'est on a joué
avec le feu on s'est brûlé des doigts et
elle s'est démutualisée donc ce qui
était la plus grande coopérative non
financière au Canada dans les années 90
en 2022 c'est seulement un souvenir on
n'est pas soumis ce qu'on appelle la loi
des trimestres quand on prend des
décisions importantes c'est quoi les
conséquences pour nos membres c'est quoi
qui fait de soi pour nos membres
[Musique]
service de proximité comme fermer des
petites meneries désuète et regroupez
des coopératives régionales
si jamais facile à annoncer des
fermetures si jamais facile privé
certains membres de certains services
parce que à l'occasion c'est le cas mais
faut penser collectivement faut penser à
demain
[Musique]
depuis les années 90 l'ajout de grandes
entreprises privées de type non
coopératifs comme holymel et BMR a
bousculer certaines valeurs coopératives
de base
[Musique]
l'arrivée de l'email participe à
l'expansion de ce lieu au Canada et
l'achat de l'abattoir red Deere en
Alberta ouvre de nouvelles portes pour
l'exportation du port en Asie le défi
c'est vraiment une fois qu'on atteint
une taille de ce niveau là avec un
chiffre d'affaires de plus de 8
milliards de dollars avec des entités
non coopératives ça demande c'est sur
une surveillance supplémentaire des
valeurs coopératives puis je pense que
c'est vraiment de par la structure de
gouvernance de soyou pour l'instant
c'est à l'abbaye mais il va y avoir à
mon avis des tensions de plus en plus
importante en les années à venir l'année
du centième anniversaire a été décevante
pour allumettes pandémie conflit de
travail réduction des abattages
fermeture d'usine et graves pénurie de
main d'oeuvre
encore aujourd'hui alors on se parle on
cherche 3000 employés
millions de dollars
chacune des divisions est solidaire de
ce lieu groupe alors oui aujourd'hui
selon agriculture BMR et solidaire de
l'email ce que Laurent Bousquet appelle
le principe des alpinistes encore des il
y a toujours un secteur mou en quatre
parts qui devient pour toutes sortes de
raisons un peu moins intéressant puis
c'est chacun son tour c'est bien certain
ce que je connais de l'histoire de la
fédérer c'est que à peu près tout le
monde est venu en mauvaise affaire à un
moment donné et puis à bénéficier de la
pluie des autres divisions pour passer à
travers
les avait fermé à chaque fois que elles
sont venues en mauvaise affaire mais on
serait fermé au total aujourd'hui
quand on joue dans la cour des grands la
politique internationale peut à tout
moment perturber les affaires de la
coopérative
principalement je pense avec la guerre
en Ukraine toute l'enjeu des
fertilisants au printemps 2022 les
immenses entrepôts de fertilisant à
Sainte-Catherine était en grande partie
vide
au lieu de la Russie l'urée est plutôt
venu d'Algérie
non travail déjà pour l'an prochain à
trouver des sources d'approvisionnement
autre pour s'assurer que au printemps
2023 on est toujours sfrisés à là pour
nos producteurs et à des prix
compétitifs
[Musique]
au conseil d'administration 14
agriculteurs et agricultrices ont à
gérer un autre immense chantier le
passage vers une agriculture plus verte
dans la dernière année on a changé le
mandat de la ferme de recherche une
partie de la ferme de recherche qui est
en transition vers l'agriculture
biologique on doit passer d'un
agriculture intensive un agriculture
écologiquement intensive
solio affirme vouloir se soumettre à
l'engagement du Canada de réduire de 30%
d'ici 2030 les gaz à effet de serre
provenant des engrais
[Musique]
des pesticides mais on n'a pas le choix
de travailler faire la recherche pour
faire ce changement là faire la
transition alors je crois la science je
crois qu'on va régler ce problème là
avec l'environnement à force de
creuser maintenant et puis de fort puis
je crois que la fédérer sur lui
aujourd'hui va être à côté de nous
autres dans ça de façon très importante
[Musique]
on est responsable d'un patrimoine qui
était bâti et accumulé par une multitude
de familles agricoles on a la
responsabilité de préserver ce
patrimoine là il faut faire en sorte que
les prochaines générations vont eux
aussi pouvoir profiter de cette
formidable outil là qui est la
coopération pour les soutenir dans le
développement et les attentes pour le
développement des entreprises
[Musique]